and finally and finally come path and
finally come combining oh my god hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen I get so so many
suggestions from all of you about things
you want me to talk about on my channel
but nothing has compared to the number
of requests I have received to talk
about food combining particularly about
this kind of Kenzie Burke woman and and
her her perspective on food combining so
I did touch on the idea very briefly a
couple weeks back when I was reviewing
Kate flowers video so you can check that
out right here but of course I want to
do the diet real justice and do a deep
deep dive for all of you guys so you can
get the full idea so first of all I want
to talk about what is food combining
well basically it's a set of rules that
suggest that you should eat some foods
together and some foods separately it's
actually not like a new new thing I
remember hearing about it before I even
became a dietitian it actually has roots
in Ayurvedic medicine however of course
these things have a way of making their
rounds and we are seeing it come back in
to kind of vogue and popularity thanks
to people like Kenzie Burke so here are
the basic rules only eat fruit on an
empty stomach don't combine starches and
proteins don't combine starches with
acidic foods don't combine different
types of protein only consume dairy
products on an empty stomach
especially milk protein should not be
mixed with fat sugar should only be
eaten alone fruits and vegetables should
be eaten separately I don't know about
you guys but when I read a list like
that I feel a combination of exhaustion
anger and a little bit of hunger but of
course it's time for me to put my big
girl pants on and get down to the
science ok so the theory behind
combining or food combining is that when
you eat fast digesting foods
like fruit and slow digesting foods like
protein at the same time it creates some
kind of like traffic jam in your gut and
not apparently can create digestive
distress and disease and toxic mother
build-up so that's what Kenzie says and
we're gonna hear a little bit more about
Kenzie's philosophy and then I'll talk a
little about the science so let's do
this with chicken on it for lunch and
then you have a sweet tooth so you want
to have some fruit which which is great
fruit is great and I'm a big fruit
person but it's just a matter of how you
eat your fruit so you know you're on
this one-way street right and you have
your chicken right here and it's it's
stopped at the stop sign
on the one-way street and then you try
to put fruit on top of that but there's
nowhere to go okay it's a one-way street
they can't go around the car they're
stuck so the fruit is essentially stuck
on top of the chicken fruit digests in
30 minutes so it's wanting to digest
it's like trying to break down but it
can't because it has nowhere to go and
also think about how like hot it is
inside of your body
we have a lot of okay
so I think Kenzie needs an anatomy class
and I'm gonna try to do my best to like
break it down so what I am envisioning
when I hear Kenzie talk about her vision
of digestion I think of like a snake
when a snake eats like an apple and it's
like a whole apple and it just like goes
into its belly and it's like bulging and
it's stuck there and of course like
nothing else can get past I don't know
if that's actually true because I'm a
dietitian I'm not like a reptile
nutritionist but that's what it sounds
like
Kenzie is suggesting it's happening here
but the reality is our stomach doesn't
contain its contents like a perfect
Pintrest parfait I mean it's more like a
smoothie by the time it gets to our
Gatton is ready to be digested and
absorbed so let's talk about that
digestion for a sec okay so the first
step of digestion happens in our mouth
we we chew our food so it's masticated
up into smaller pieces and then the
enzymes get to work starting to break
them down so amylase works on the
carbohydrates we're eating and lipase
works on the fats when the bolus or the
food ball I guess you could say enters
our stomach gastric acid is released as
this more enzymes to keep the digestion
flow in so we see lipase again for fat
pepsin for protein and amylase for carbs
so let's stick with Kenzie's analogy of
the kind of like one way street cuz it's
held a lot more pleasant than the snake
imagery I've got going on here but the
reality is our digestive system is not a
one-way street it's more like a six-lane
Highway and when we eat something the
food finds a lane and then our body
sends out messages to get the enzymes
the appropriate enzymes needed to help
break it down and all of these things
are happening simultaneously it's not
like one food is being broken down at
once on top of that there's no such
thing as foods only consisting of one
food group
so these food rules seem really
arbitrary at best and really faulty and
problematic at worst I mean all whole
foods contain a variety of food
components like fat carbs and protein
and it's our body's job to be equipped
with the right enzymes and variety of
enzymes to help break those foods down
for digestion and absorption for example
fruits and vegetables contain carbs we
know that but a lot of them also contain
small amounts of protein and fat animal
foods like meats for example often
contain protein but also fat it's very
hard to find proteins that are devoid of
fat at the same time we see things like
grains grains are really great source of
carbohydrates but also protein and
sometimes even fat as well so it only
makes sense that our body's equipped to
be able to handle whatever cocktail of
things we put into it and to try to
digest all of that
optimizing your energy so our digestive
systems use the most energy out of any
single part in our body uses 80 to 90
percent of our energy I tried to
fact-check that as best as I could and I
could not find any sources that suggests
that we use 80 to 90 percent of our
entire energy to digest food the best
number I was able to find was 10% which
honestly makes a lot more sense I feel
like if we were using 80 to 90 percent
of our energy dust just to digest food
we would need a hell of a lot more
energy so just wanted to make that clear
so if you eat in a way where you're
freeing some of that energy up and your
food can just go right through you
you are freeing up energy within your
body to do other things like to rebuild
your skin's collagen to shed off weight
easily and permanently energy ok so I
just want to clear that piece up as well
because I don't really buy into this
idea that we want food to go through us
quickly I think that's so weird
I mean do you like diarrhea I don't like
diarrhea it's never been part you know
one of my top favorite pastimes but the
reality is we actually want food to go
through our digestive tract slower
because that means more satiety when
food kind of when you eat something and
then you're starving again in half an
hour it usually means that those kinds
of foods are not very satiating and it's
gonna potentially lead to overeating it
spikes your blood sugar and then crashes
you right back down slow digesting foods
also helped us normalize our blood sugar
levels so for example if you just have
like a piece of candy for example which
is just straight-up carbohydrates
straight up simple sugars without any
fiber protein or fats to slow it down we
see a spike in our blood sugar and then
a crash shortly after and we're hungry
again right so that is why I actually
recommend food combining and I'll talk
more about this in a bit where we want
to combine a source of carbohydrates
with our protein fiber or fats so some
kind of describe
c--'s in philosophy going on here but I
guess Kenzie's really much more
concerned about the collagen and
permanent weight loss which is does make
sense okay I also want to talk about
thermogenesis so thermogenesis is the
process where our body creates heat as a
byproduct of breaking down and digesting
and absorbing food so this is where the
idea of kind of like burning calories
comes from because calorie is just a
measure of heat so some foods actually
have a higher thermogenic rate because
it takes our body more energy to help
break it down and absorb it which is
actually thought of as kind of a good
thing because it means a slight boost in
our metabolic rate it's just kind of
strange to me that Kenzie sees all those
kinds of things the heat generation as
being problematic when really the
science tells us otherwise and I also
eat good portion meals like I don't
restrict myself in any way and I go to
bed with a flat stomach and I feel
amazing and I know that I'm just getting
all the nutrients from my food so
there's a lot to unpack there but first
of all let me just talk about some of
the benefits that she just noted light
energized flat stomach feeling amazing
none of those things have to do with
food combining for the energized thing
for example this has nothing to do with
the fact that you know maybe you are
eating avocados separate from your egg
for example this has probably a lot more
to do with the fact that she may be
staying hydrated not overeating
high-calorie high-fat foods spreading
her calories out throughout the day and
not skipping meals and then getting
ravenous and eating a huge meal before
dinner
focusing on stress physical activity and
of course sleep all those things are way
way better predictors of feeling
energized
and you know combining certain foods or
separating certain foods in your day I
think it's easy for a youtuber to
pinpoint a very specific element in
their diet as the reason for their their
health however the evidence really does
suggest otherwise that all of these
other things that she's likely also
doing are much better predictors and I
haven't even touched on things like the
social determinants of health which we
know are the biggest predictors of
overall well-being
my entire body transformed and I
immediately started to notice changes
within my body and four weeks into it I
mean note I also was working out
throughout this whole thing and I've
also been very health conscious but with
honestly Kenzi my thinking here is that
the reason for your flat stomach is
largely genetic and the fact that you've
never housed a human in there but also
you pointed out yourself that you were
exercising a lot and paying attention to
what you eat whatever that means so
those are probably much bigger
predictors than this food combining
magic and mama juju but of course I want
to talk a bit about the science behind
bloating so that you guys have a little
bit more context so one of the claims of
food combining is that the fast
digesting foods and slow digesting foods
are digesting at different rates and the
slow digesting foods end up sitting in
your gut and rotting which causes
bloating
the reality is Bustos just like sit
around untouched in your stomach for
long periods of time or like any periods
of time our stomach is incredibly acidic
and our body will start to very quickly
break down anything that's in there as
for your intestines this makes a little
bit more sense because our large
intestine houses a wide variety of good
bacteria and foods that we don't break
down for example like fiber ferment
there and cause yeah so for example
that's why you got gas when you eat like
a lot of cabbage or a lot of broccoli or
cauliflower raw vegetables for example
but that's actually not all bad I mean
the byproduct of this process is things
like short chain fatty acid
which we know are really good for blood
sugar control reducing the risk of
disease and inflammation some other
likely reasons why you might be
experiencing bloating are things like
legitimate food intolerances or eating
too fast or too much especially foods
that are high in fat or high salt or
high-calorie some of those sulfurous
vegetables that we just talked about
that ferment in the gut or sugar free
foods that also can ferment in the gut
as well as just like hormones like
during that time of the month in fact if
you're suffering from chronic bloating
it could be a symptom of something more
serious
so always speak to a registered
dietician or doctor if this sounds like
you before your symptoms get exacerbated
by something like food combining from
there so you just pick one it doesn't
have to be a super overwhelming thing
you pick one and then from there you
pick your vegetables so I always say
half or more than half of your plate
should be vegetables vegetables optimize
digestion vegetables are amazing for you
vegetables are your best friend they are
on neutral food they can digest with
anything like leafy greens can digest
with anything they even digest with
fruits of it uh the rules like before we
couldn't eat vegetables and and fruit
and now we the greens are a neutral
they're magic so I agree with Kensie
here that I also like to try to fill
like half my plate with vegetables best
vegetables are amazing vegetables are
magic vegetables are great for digestion
yes we agree on this one point Kenzi
however I want to talk about this whole
idea of vegetables being neutral aside
from the kind of moral language that is
associated with that what I think she's
getting at is that in the food combining
world whose could either be acidic
alkaline or neutral and eating the wrong
foods can apparently alter your ph which
of course can disrupt your digestion
yes our enzymes need an optical pH to
function however there's no evidence to
suggest that eating specific alkaline or
acidic or neutral foods
have a significant impact on our
digestive tract pH and even if it could
change things your body would find a way
to correct it so here's how your stomach
lining contains cells that help to
regulate its pH level if pH was to
change then your body would secrete more
gastric acid to bring it back into line
the same kind of thing happens in your
intestines which are more alkaline
basically if it got too acidic in there
then your pancreas would secrete
bicarbonate acid to neutralize the
gastric acid coming from the stomach
either way your pH levels are tightly
controlled and regulated by the your
body and not the food you eat thank you
next time it was my thing like sometimes
even twice a day that was my go-to snack
cutting out apple and almond butter
together alone
like those two together completely
changed my life like I was bloated after
I had apple and almond butter every
single time I didn't know why I thought
it was healthy there to Whole Foods like
why why wouldn't that work but it was
because the almonds take way longer to
digest than the apples use energy to try
to break that down and I was causing
bloat I swear I lost it I don't like to
talk about weight but I lost weight when
I started food combining and I swear the
Apple and almond butter was such a big
thing tiniest chips that make the
biggest difference I can't help but like
I'm trying not to poke fun at this but
honestly it's funny how much she's
harping on an apple and almond butter
but also this diet just sounds so
delusional I mean I I don't know if if
she ever plays back this video and
listens to some of these statements but
if I were to do that I would be I would
hope that I would see some issue here
but I want to talk about food combining
in the context of weight loss because I
understand from a lot of your messages
that this is really where your interest
lies so basically to date I was only
able to find one study on food combining
and weight loss and they
see what they did was they come they
divvied up the participants into one
group that was put on a food combining
diet and another group that was put on a
balanced food diet both groups were only
allowed to eat 1,100 calories which in
my books is starvation and I'm surprised
it even made it past ethics however not
surprisingly considering how low-calorie
this diet was both groups lost weight
and the conclusion was that food
combining offered no benefits compared
to a general balanced diet and of course
this is a short-term study as they all
are but I would be really surprised if
anyone was able to maintain that weight
lost 95% of people gain back the weight
that they lose on diets and usually then
even more so so I say do not try this at
home I was really struggling about two
years ago I got really into working out
I was obsessed with it and I'm a very
obsessive person so I couldn't just stop
with the working out it was like I
needed more and I wanted more so I got
really interested in the food I ate and
then I got also kind of obsessive with
how I looked and a lot of that had to do
with social media it was like I always
saw these models I always thought these
Fitness influencers and I would see them
posting like burgers and french fries
and it just didn't add up to me I could
not understand like how do they do that
and I also didn't feel like I could find
the truth like I would find someone and
I would think okay I'm gonna try this
system and for it to not work for me and
to like come to find that maybe they
were restricting more than what they had
posted and I just felt super super
frustrated so I just want to flag this
little testimonial and and confessional
in the middle of Kenzie's video here
because when I hear this I honestly I
hear my former self when I was really in
the throes of disordered eating and
orthorexia and I'm not Kenzie's doctors
so this is by no means you know me
trying to diagnose anything but this
sounds very much like disordered eating
disguised by wellness culture and a
quest for better health this is the lure
of orthorexia this is why it's so easy
to fall victim to fall into this trap
because it's all you know not done out
of vanity it's for health so there
there's there's this allure of you know
self-care but really any obsession with
wellness is problematic and this is her
language obsession that's the word that
she used she talked about being
constantly obsessed and the term
obsession or obsessed is inherent and
part of the definition of or threat SIA
[Music]
and I created the 21 days to your best
body stories that I receive of other
girls that have done this reset that
have had severe bloating like severe
bloating they never thought there was a
cure within three days of doing food
combining and eating plant-based foods
everything was transformed for them it's
really good to get in tune with your
body health is a ripple effects I'm here
to get you started I'm here to provide
you inspiration I'm here to provide you
information but once you start to feel
good you will be hungry for more and you
will evolve and here's the sales pitch
so Kenzie is talking about how she's now
a certified health coach and these
health coaching programs the
qualifications and schooling required
can range from anywhere between like a
few weeks unlike an online program to
maybe like a year when I looked deeper
at her credentials I found that it does
not require a kind of license the same
way that being a registered dietician
would so she's free to give nutrition
advice as long as she doesn't call
herself a registered dietician so the
reason behind not needing a license is
that they're not seen as being a public
health concern however I would say that
prescribing certain diets or lifestyles
on a large platform to a large audience
like YouTube and pushing a 21-day body
reset program is definitely harming to
the public and a public health concern
the
problem is that a lot of people don't
realize and understand the difference
between a registered dietician or
nutritious and a health coach and for
that reason people don't really realize
how much or how little education and
training and expertise their so-called
expert has and of course she has a
program that she's pushing not surprised
if you're looking for a way to get
started you should do my 21-day reset I
have all the information you could ever
need about food combining on my page and
I don't have lengthy information on it
because I don't want to overwhelm anyone
I know should there's no lengthy
information and it's not because she
doesn't want to overwhelm anyone it's
because she wants to deceive everyone
because there is no lengthy information
I have given you all the information the
legitimate information right here
so now let's flip the switch and talk
about some situations where food
combining could actually be beneficial
so first of all combining iron rich
foods with vitamin C rich foods so there
are two types of iron heme iron found in
animal products and non heme iron found
in plant-based products and non heme
iron is not absorbed as readily and
effectively or efficiently as heme iron
so one way to increase the absorption is
to pair it with a vitamin C rich food so
that's why we recommend combining things
like beans and lentils and legumes with
things like tomatoes or bell peppers or
citrus fruits this would be really
important information for Kenzi to share
with her plant-based friends and
followers however this would be
prohibited by the standards of the food
combining God's number two fat soluble
vitamins with a source of fat so your
fat soluble vitamins like vitamin A D E
and K are best absorbed with some kind
of source of fat so research has found
the carotenoid rich fruits and veggies
like your orange and red and green
vegetables are best with a little bit of
oil or fat to increase the absorption so
that's why for example we always
recommend having full fat salad dressing
on your salad greens like wise it'd be
really really important to get some fat
with your vitamin A rich fruit so for
example pairing mango with cashews or
watermelon with avocado all of those
mean really great ways to reap the
benefits of your produce however of
course that would be outlawed by the
food combining rules so that sucks
and finally combining carbohydrates with
a source of protein or fat so contrary
to the food combining rules there's
actually a lot of benefits to adding
some fat or protein in with your
carbohydrates at your meals and snacks
so for example in sports nutrition we
want to pair our carbohydrates with our
protein after a workout to help to
replenish our glycogen stores and repair
those torn sore muscles
likewise blood sugar control is also a
really important reason to add a little
bit of protein or fat in with our
carbohydrates so once that he found that
people had much
better blood sugar levels after
combining some lentils with their potato
as opposed to just having the potato all
on its own
alas none of these things would be
allowed if you just followed those
stupid food combining rules all right
folks
real talk these rules are bogus in my
books however the reality is anytime you
impose a set of rules on you on yourself
and your eating you cut out a ton of
food the more rules
the fewer eating options that you have
and at the end of the day that may just
result in you eating less which may
result in weight loss and may also
result in less bloating because of just
the quality of foods that you're
consuming it's not about you pairing an
apple with a carrot it's the fact that
you're just consuming less food so yeah
I just want to like flag that I get that
I'm being a little bit harsh in this
video more so than I have been recently
but it's really because of Kenzie's tone
and the fact that Kensie very much like
Frehley is positioning herself as a kind
of health guru and a health coach or
wellness health coach and I find that
really problematic because there's a lot
of misinformation embedded in her videos
and her reset program that she's
peddling so I really do have to call
this out this is not just a youtuber
who's sharing what she eats in a day
saying this is this is what feels good
for me she is pushing and marketing a
whole program and herself as an expert
who is out there lending expertise
expertise and recommendations and
prescriptions so I had to lay down the
law on this one a little bit and and
yeah I mean it is what it is so guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below about any other diets
or people who you'd like me to review
I'd love to see them we're constantly
compiling that list and trying our best
to make our way through subscribe to the
channel and don't forget to check out my
playlist of some other really great what
I eat in a day youtuber review videos
right here alright see you guys next
time bye
you